un viaje real cancelado por el clima de
tensión en Francia el presidente
Emmanuel confirmó que la visita del Rey
Carlos III será aplazada debido a la ola
de manifestaciones que entró en su
noveno día el jueves y que dio lugar a
hechos de violencia en varias ciudades
del país
los sindicatos anunciaron una nueva
jornada de movilización el martes y la
visita del Rey estaba prevista del lunes
al miércoles creo que no estaríamos
serios y careceríamos de sentido común
si propusiéramos a Su Majestad el rey y
a la reina consorte que vinieran a
visitarnos en medio de las
manifestaciones
el rey tenía previsto viajar a Francia
el domingo por tres días en una
importante visita de estado pero el país
se ha visto afectado por las huelgas y
protestas masivas tras la adopción del
proyecto de ley que breve subir la edad
legal de jubilación de 62 a 64 años
Ahora hay protestas y huelgas por todas
partes si es normal ya que París es una
ciudad con verdaderos residentes sí es
una ciudad turística pero no es solo eso
hay gente que vive aquí y que tienen
necesidades
más de un millón de personas
participaron en las protestas del jueves
según el gobierno y tres coma cinco
millones según los sindicatos los
manifestantes y las organizaciones
sociales culpan al gobierno por no
prestar atención a la creciente
indignación ciudadana también lo acusan
de haber adoptado la reforma gracias al
uso de poderes especiales que forzaron
la aprobación del proyecto sin el voto
de la asamblea nacional